[موسيقى]
الهند بلد ترك في روح قطعه منه ونظره
مختلفه للعالم
ثقافات والاديان المندمجه بتناغم انسدم
واحد
والمدن التي تختلف كل منها عن الملاصقه
لها اختلاف السماء عن الارض جعل اكتشاف كل
مدينه منها يحتاج لايام
[موسيقى]
ولكن لقصر رحلتي لم يسمح لي الوقت بقضاء
اكثر من يوم واحد في اكثر المدن سحرا
مدينه جيبور او المدينه الورديه
[موسيقى]
هي عاصمه ولايه راجستان
بطله الكثير من الافلام الهنديه واحده من
اهم المراكز التجاريه ومركز كثير من اعراس
بوليود
[موسيقى]
تدخل المدينه من بوابه باللون الوردي
الهادئ لترى بعدها ان اللون الوردي يكسو
المدينه باكملها
ويرجع السر لعام
1876 حين امر المهرج رامسينج بطلاء
المدينه كامله باللون الوردي حيث كان
اللون الرامز للضيافه في الهند وقتها وذلك
ترحيبا بالامير البرت زوج الملكه فيكتوريا
لتتحول المدينه الى شاهده على العجائب
الهندسه المعماريه
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن ان ازور جايبور دون زياره اشهر
معالمها حسني عامر او امبر فورد
الفناء ضخم والبوابات المهيبه التجول داخل
الحصن يعتبر ضربا من دروب الخيال
فهو مبني على تلال ارفالي ويطل على بحيره
موته التي كانت تعد قديما بمثابه سد دفاعي
للحصن قام الحاكم رجما سينغ الذي كان ملك
عشيرته كاتشواها ببناء الحصن وشيد حولها
سور ضخم متعرج فوق الهضاب
تظنه في الوهله الاولى صوره الصين العظيم
لشده تشابه بينهما
[موسيقى]
وهو سور جايغارا الحصن المنيع الحامي لحسن
عامر حيث ان الاثنين متصلان بممر تحت
الارض وكان الهدف منه ان يكون طريقا
للهروب في اوقات الحرب
[موسيقى]
ويعد حصن عامر ضمن مواقع التراثي العالمي
لمنظمه اليونسكو
[موسيقى]
هيكل الحصن الوردي مبني من الحجر الرملي
الاحمر والرخام والتجول فيه هو رحله في حد
ذاته فانت تمر عبر ممرات كانت قبل ذلك تعج
بالحركه حيث كانت مقرا للاسره المالكه
وحشيتها لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي جايبور
الهند